Steven you weren't supposed to see any of
this what are you you sure you want to know
I can't tell the difference
between my waking life and dreams
am i like some sort of secret agent
it's a little more complicated than that
marvel studios moon knight
Welcome back everyone
this will be my new moon knight trailer video
marvel just dropped a bunch of brand new footage
we'll break it all down there's also a couple
blade easter eggs in here that i'll explain
because there is a connection between moonite
and blade inside the mcu sure you're ready for
that mr whitman episodes are dropping really soon
i'll be doing videos for all them so be sure to
subscribe to get them if you're brand new to my
channel we're also doing a spider man no way home
giveaway for the digital release because they're
releasing it this week all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your favorite moon
knight easter egg on the video a lot of you
asking if moon knight would ever cross paths
with spider-man because they're both kind of like
ground level heroes they both do have a measure
of special powers although moon knight technically
would be more powerful than spider-man as long as
he's under a full enough moon because he gets
his powers from Khonshu the egyptian moon god
his powers are tied to the phases of the moon so
the more full the moon becomes the more powerful
he becomes there been more recent stories where he
actually winds up fighting a bunch of the avengers
because he has to execute the will of Khonshu
that's why they call him the fist of Khonshu
as Khonshu's avatar he's sort of bound to do his
will and sometimes that puts him at odds with
a lot of the other heroes because Khonshu funny
enough played by f murray abraham earliest voiced
by him obviously he's not going to be in the
costume because it's all motion capture Khonshu
is a very capricious god he is very jealous and
he hates all other gods for the most part the
whole idea though is that marc specter moon knight
tries to use his powers to help people often times
in spite of the things that Khonshu wants him to
do the god Khonshu does not care about making the
world a better place usually he just worried about
himself his own position in the cosmos and larger
cosmic problems but the really cool thing that
they do with this new trailer footage is give us
a bunch more scenes showing you the group dynamics
inside his own head as the different personalities
speak to each other now so far in all the trailers
we've really only seen two different personalities
steven grant and marc spector like the two of
them are talking to each other in this trailer
and marc spector has surfaced and is explaining
everything to steven grant so when they're talking
to each other inside this cell he's seeing a
reflection but he's actually just imagining
himself seeing a reflection speaking to him the
name that marvel gave this trailer is mercenary
because marc spector was a mercenary before he
became moon knight i'm assuming this scene is
happening later during episode one because the
director the producer said that when the series
picks up like at the beginning of episode 1 he
thinks that he's stephen grant and he only learns
the truth about marc spector and his backstory
moon knight later in the episode like he wakes up
as steven grant and weird things start happening
he starts noticing little clues little references
and then things get crazy and eventually the
marc spector personality surfaces inside his head
and then explains everything to him about how
he became moon knight no no no we're really marc
spector we just created you stephen grant also
when he's inside this cell talking to himself
it's the same cell when he's doing his own version
of a superhero hulk out moment activating his moon
knight powers in the other trailer by switching
between personalities you also notice during this
other trailer footage there's a grc advertisement
on the bus in egypt where this is taking place
that's the global repatriation council that was
featured during falcon and winter soldier they're
like the international organization dedicated
to sending everybody back to their original
countries of origin after the blip in avengers
end game the whole idea is that after the snap in
avengers infinity war half the population vanishes
so everybody all over the world slowly migrates to
different countries and bands together for support
for resources and when that happened people moved
into a lot of other people's homes who'd been
snapped because they didn't need him anymore
they had a big joke about this at the beginning
of spider-man far from home when aunt may was
like i just came back in this apartment and the
wife thought that i was the husband's mistress so
after the blip when everybody came back all those
blip people wanted their old stuff back their old
property their old homes and so on so galaxy
brain's solution was to send everybody back to
where they came from which obviously didn't work
out the way they wanted it to the way that falcon
and winter soldier portrayed the grc is they were
very antagonistic very ineffectual not necessarily
evil but not good either it was the whole reason
why that flag smasher group formed stole the super
soldier serum and was going around hurting the grc
stealing all their supplies and giving it to other
people who really needed them if you remember all
the spider-man far from home passport easter eggs
for spider-man's character they did the exact
same thing with marc spector moon knight so
if you look at his passport here the birth date
that they list here march 9th 1987 is actually a
reference to oscar isaac's birthday in real life
he was born march 9th the year of his birth 1987
was the year that marvel comics had moon knight
join the west coast avengers and we know that
moonette will eventually join the avengers at
some point in the future like avengers 5 or some
future avengers movie after that there's a couple
other crossovers that he'll have in marvel phase
4 before that which i'll talk about in a second
getting to the blade of it all and what's going on
with kit harington's black knight character he got
his current passport december 14 2018 that also
means that he was not snapped by thanos because
the snap happened earlier in the year during 2018
so he would not have been able to get this
passport if he'd been snapped it expires in 2028
that's just because u.s passports typically have a
10-year renewal cycle they haven't fully explained
when moon knight takes place in the marvel phase
4 timeline but unless they say otherwise i'm
assuming it just takes place several months or
a year or so after the events of avengers end
game like at some point during 2024 there's also
a really cool kang the conqueror easter egg that
some of you may have spotted in the trailer too
through the rama version of kang from ancient
egypt a lot of people asked if there's going to
be any kind of kang cameos during this series i
do not think that kang is going to show up during
moon knight there's just a tangential connection
because of kang's backstory in the mcu the very
first time that kang the conqueror debuted he
actually debuted as a character called rama tut
and the way that they explained this later in
marvel comics is that he was just one of the alter
egos that kang used when he was time traveling and
it was just on the first time travel mission that
he went on fun doctor doom connection for those
of you that are hyped up to see dr doom show up
in the mcu at some point kang actually stole the
plans for his first time machine from dr doom so
dr doom created a time machine during the present
day of the avengers stories in marvel comics
then in the distant future kang the conqueror
a student of history finds those plans basically
steals them repurposes them and creates his first
time machine but he went back to ancient egypt
and set himself up as this pharaoh ruling over
egypt calling himself rama tut moon knight trades
a lot on egyptian mythology in the egyptian gods
so during the trailer there's a scarab that he
picks up it's the same scarab that you see ethan
hawke's character using to find the dig site here
where i believe marc spector finds the statue of
Khonshu but there was a very recent story where
moon knight actually goes up against king the
conqueror fighting this war with him across time
for a couple different totems that kang had when
he was rama tut one of them is a scarab that has
the power to create time rifts now i think this
scarab is going to be a little bit different but
we're just bumping up against a lot of the kang
mythology and bringing the easter eggs full circle
oscar isaac you'll probably remember is apocalypse
in the fox x-men movies the fox marvel universe
when kang got tired of ruling over ancient egypt
instead of apocalypse as his successor so because
we're trading so heavily on egyptian mythology
i'm hoping they make a couple sly references and
winks at apocalypse during the moon knight series
just because of oscar isaac i don't think we're
going to see a ton of kang the conqueror stuff
until we get to ant-man 3 quantum media like
that's supposed to be the first movie where
you really see him as a big character in the mcu
the version that we saw during the loki series
was actually just the he who remains version of
kang just another variant but based more on the
immortus version of kang like kang at the end
of his timeline who become less evil i know we
have the multiverse illuminati coming up during
doctor strange multiverse of madness so people
are wondering about the council of kangs we have
the council of reeds and marvel comics a lot of
multiverse going on during marvel phase four but
the way the showrunner and the producers talked
about the moon knight series they actually said
that it wasn't directly connected to a lot of the
bigger crazier stuff that's happening in marvel
phase 4 right now and i think they were mostly
referencing the multiverse stuff but the brand
new werewolf by night character is supposed to
appear during moon knight because moon knight
debuted for the first time in a werewolf by
night story so like there's a close connection
between those two characters that goes way way
back and they just confirmed that mahershala
ali's blade character is supposed to show up
next in the marvel universe in the werewolf finite
special one shot that they're doing for disney
plus this halloween my early theory with all these
darker crossovers though between moon knight blade
kid harrington's black knight werewolf by night is
that they're doing them this way probably because
moon knight werewolf by night and kid harrington's
black knight will all appear during the new blade
movie like you have the eternals post credit
scene where you hear mcu blade and you're seeing
kit harington pick up the ebony blade but he's
about to become the black knight then you learn
about the werewolf by night character during the
moon knight series or you get a teaser for him
and then during the werewolf by night special all
the characters come back and they tease under the
big crossover which they pay off in the blade
movie if you spotted any other easter eggs in
this trailer that i didn't talk about in the
video just write them below in the comments
we're getting moon knight episodes in a couple
weeks i'll be doing videos for all them make
sure you have alerts enabled for my channel so you
don't miss those congratulations to wrath you're
the giveaway winner from my last big marvel video
please email me on the about page of my channel so
i can get your contact details everyone click here
for that new spider-man no way home deleted scenes
video it's hilarious and click here for my other
new moon knight video with all the hulk easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!